remember I said to you just like
superannuation the basic code that this
is something that's happening yearly on
an ongoing basis
so a duty are a special type of
investment in you is a special type of
investment where additional amounts are
reinvested how often would you guess
based on the name and every year anyway
right now let me contrast this this
situation here so what we're looking at
all the way back in FM to a question you
might get it FM two years you've got a
thousand dollars you're going to put it
in the bank for five years and it's
going to invest that nine percent per
annum
. never give that back in FM - I would
have said here's sum of money here's an
amount of time here is an interest rate
and then you can crunch that into either
you've got two formulas which to form is
dear you might have got compound
interests or centimeters okay so that's
fine it's just a formula but what we
should know is this keyword anyways so
this is different
give me by the way you're going to need
your calculator system so will I they're
not just going to put a thousand dollars
in and then just let it sit there for
five years
what they're going to do is they're
going to put a thousand dollars IAM and
then they're going to reinvest five
thousand dollars in addition to your
original thousand dollars every year
right to add a minimum you're putting
$5,000 this ad if your pocket right and
then your interest is going to grow and
grow and grow as you go now there are
two ways to go about this to a purchase
and this is really cheesy so just bear
with me approach one is the work you'll
see why I mean it's the worm in a second
actually
going do you do really okay how did I
say she's away the warmer person okay I
wondered tell me how it is very clearly
headed crawl off the ground okay you
have like sweaty things no anyway I can
have so if you are gonna sit down let me
and I'm going to introduce facilitation
a sense or amount and it is therefore
the number of years that you had your
investment in there okay so that is
equal the amount at what would take of
the kiddies how continue okay awesome
okay so remember they're doing a
thousand dollars in doing over and over
and over again okay so a 1 will be the
amount off saw one year does that make
sense just the amount after one year to
what we don't also want you one matter
shits about did your first Alvin dollars
but then what happens what happens well
after that year elapses they say hey
that's an interest good on your buddy
right so what's going to happen is for a
to the first thing that happens is that
amount you had before is going to
increase by nine percent right now we
can do this in a variety of ways right
agree with the quickest way possible
what should I multiply this by to make
it grow by nine percent
I'll give you a clue it starts with a
one one point zero nine will do it or
alternatively one hundred and nine
percent okay however you need to learn
to recognize when to use decimals and
how to convert our percentage like this
into a thing like that because really to
get that decimal place wrong 1.9 is a
common thing to put it as incorrect so I
think it's good to practice that if you
want though
you could write could you 9% afterwards
yeah
they've given me interest that's good
but remember we said Hayes is different
- mmm - we don't scale let the money sit
there
we're going to 40th another thousand
dollars right so therefore here's what
happened to your original validol and
then you add another thousand okay now
this is where your calculator comes in I
now know I can evaluate this what the
amount is are two years and these
numbers are still - what I cannot do
ahead future no you right okay
so there you go two years at us how many
use my doing this for 35 years
okay so I'm going to now think about
what happens at the end of the third
year answer the same thing happened in
the second year so the world they
crawled along closely and making
progress chewing through this so it's
going to go charge because I hope you
will have it elapsed before you actually
go back so there would be a drop I
should point out this is frequently and
I'm trying to draw this contract out
this is frequently one of the easiest
things to confuse this kind of problem
just look at the way this is set out
you'll see a number of money a number of
times the number of integer right it's
exactly the same stuff that goes into a
compound interest problem okay so I can
tell you right now between both of these
before
that students see these three numbers
and they can't tell which is which
because it's a safe piece of admission
that goes in each so please pay
attention carefully because this is so
healing for students in Iran so do you
take what you had last year and you get
interests right but then in addition to
interest you say well I'm going to
reinvest
now I don't know what this is now so
you're going to have to work out to me
what I have another set of this and then
add a thousand work we got creative
doesn't make anyone three to seven eight
point one one zero yeah it's all the
things all four G desolation now how
many times I going to happens to do this
five times right and now hopefully you
can see why I am calling this the worms
approach because all I can do is just
slowly chew through this along the
ground and we're going to contrast it to
another way in a minute so this finish
is out you can see it solve his patent
solar number one five point five nine
iron benign every age or weight in one
okay however you have to agree on that
okay I want to point out a couple of
things that is this is war okay this is
one reason why we called this okay now I
want to point out two things number one
is if we're going to do this I'll show
you a second approach number two to
really do this over a long period of
time you really need a formula for this
right or at least like a table which
sort of makes a lovely to eat the
numbers easier to work out we won't get
to that in the copy room well actually
two and recess tomorrow don't forget to
run we'll get through the coming week
but that number the NDI well someone was
really to me in the computing wine is
fine edition gaming on some that other
day is that's a finish point okay so
that's